- Hello, welcome to Ed
Talks with Khan Academy,
where we talk to experts
in the field of education.
Today we have with us Sophie Bosmeny,
who is with Khan Kids
and she's gonna update us
on what's going on with Khan Kids
or up to eight year olds,
so we are looking forward to
hearing what she has to say.
Before we get started a
reminder that Khan Academy
is a non-profit and we rely on donations
to keep up the work that we are doing.
So you will find at KhanAcademy.org/donate
the place where you can make a donation,
whatever you can give is appreciated
and thank you for helping us
to continue to do this work.
We also wanna recognize a few companies
that really in the time
of COVID-19 stepped up
to help us make sure we could meet
the increasing demand for what we do.
That includes Bank of
America, AT&T, Google.org,
Novartis, Fastly and
General Motors, thank you.
And finally, if you have
missed some of these Ed Talks
or Homerooms you can find
us in your podcast app
at Homeroom with Sal and
replay the audio versions
of these discussions.
So we look forward to
seeing you there as well.
And with that, I will welcome Sophie.
Thank you for joining us today.
- Thank you for having me, Kristen.
It's great to see you
and I'm really excited
to be talking about Khan Academy Kids.
- Excellent.
So let's start off.
Tell us a little bit about yourself.
What's your role at Khan Academy Kids?
- Well, it actually goes back a little way
when I worked at Khan Academy.
So I started out working on Khan Academy
thinking a lot about how we
get into school districts
around the country so I worked
as a Partnerships Manager
at Khan Academy for few years,
and then just after Khan Academy
acquired Duck Duck Moose,
which was a full profit
suite of early learning apps
that wanted to have even more impact
and so joined Khan Academy.
I found the pool of
early childhood education
and those littlest learners so exciting
that I came and worked
on Khan Academy Kids.
And now I work on Khan Academy Kids,
I work on strategy and I
work on our partnerships
with preschools and with school districts
around the country.
- That's great.
So we often have students who are watching
and many of us are in careers that
maybe aren't the things
that students who are in
middle or high school think about,
how did you end up in
this role of partnerships
and linking people together?
- That's a good question and
I think it's something that
I like to talk about a little bit because
it was kind of a roundabout path
and it's not like when I was
in high school I thought,
I wanna go and work for
what I think is the best
ed tech company in the
world and do partnerships
that certainly wasn't on my radar.
I grew up in Australia I
don't know if you can tell
from my accent.
(Kristen laughs)
- A little bit.
- I had really supportive
parents who so wanted me
to pursue whatever I was interested in
and they had a really strong preference
for that to be medicine or the law
that I would maybe become
a doctor or an attorney.
And so I did go down that
path and became an attorney
in Australia and I loved
that work and at some point
that work brought me out to the U.S
and that was to study and to work
and so I was an international
student out here
doing a graduate degree and
that's when I discovered
Khan Academy, I thought a lot about,
well, what is it that I really love doing?
And that's connecting
people like you said,
it's thinking about,
okay, what are the big problems
that we should be solving and
trying to prioritize things,
because we can't quite do everything.
And so a job in
partnerships and in strategy
came to make a lot of sense,
but I don't want anyone to think that
that was a neat path though
that made a lot of sense at the time.
There was certainly times where I thought,
oh gosh, I spent all this
time going to law school
maybe I should use that.
And it's turned out that I
do, I do use my law degree
and I use a lot of other skills as well.
So yeah my message would
be enjoy that journey
and get excited about the
fact that you might not even
know sitting here right now what it is
that you might end up really loving doing
in five or 10 years time,
which was definitely my experience.
- That was totally my experience as well.
And I can tell a story now from where I am
of how I got here that sounds
like it was all a plan,
but it was not at any particular time,
there were different forks
that would have led me
in different directions
so I totally agree.
And I always like to tell
people to just be open
to what might come down the path
as opportunities arise as well.
That's fascinating.
I had no idea you'd been to law school
even though we've worked
together for a while
so I'm glad I asked.
(Kristen laughs)
- Yeah.
- Let's switch over to Khan Academy Kids.
For those who aren't familiar with it.
Tell us a little bit about it.
How is it different than
the Khan Academy main site
that folks go to?
Fill us in.
- Yeah, so Khan Academy Kids
is a part of Khan Academy.
So we all work under one umbrella
on the same mission of providing
a free world-class education
to anyone anywhere.
And Khan Academy Kids takes
that mission and says,
okay, in order to deliver on that
it's going to be really
important that kids
arrive at third grade able to read
and able to be in the classroom
and feeling like they're enjoying math.
And the way that we approach
that at Khan Academy Kids
is we've built a program that
covers all of those things.
So it's not just one subject
and it's in a mobile app,
which is really important
for younger learners
to be able to drag and drop things
and have something that meets their needs
before they can read and actually navigate
a desktop computer.
And so I think you're
seeing some of the footage
of just how fun and bright and cool it is.
But the big differences I would say
Khan Academy is for grades two through 12,
and it has math and ELA
for grades two through 12,
and a range of other subjects
for middle and high school,
Khan Academy Kids is for ages
two years to eight years.
So it goes up two and
through second grade,
getting kids ready for third grade
when they would move
on and use Khan Academy
so that's one big difference.
I mentioned that Khan
Academy Kids is a mobile app.
So the way that you
access Khan Academy Kids
is through the app store that you use.
So that could be the Apple App Store,
it could be Google Play,
it could even be Amazon
and then it would be
on your mobile device.
So here we can see there's
a tablet being used
but it could also be a mobile phone
or even a Chromebook.
Khan Academy is also available
on the App Store as an app,
it's a different separate app.
So you would search for Khan Academy
versus Khan Academy Kids in the App Store.
There are two different
apps in the App Store.
And Khan Academy is also
available on the web
so on your desktop computer,
that's one big difference.
I would say, though there
are more similarities
than there are differences.
The idea is to make
learning really joyful,
to meet learners where they're at,
whether they're struggling with something
or really accelerating and
loving a particular area
of their learning.
And then also increasingly the
goal is to support teachers
and their students in classrooms
and both Khan Academy and Khan
Academy Kids are doing that.
So I think that's some
of the main similarities
and differences between Khan
Academy and Khan Academy Kids.
- I love that.
Yeah I usually think of it as thinking
we're headed towards the same goal,
but kids who are two
through eight years old
developmentally are very
different than older kids
and just designing one
experience really isn't possible.
And so having these two separate
experiences really gives us
the strength of being able
to really, as you said,
meet students where they are,
so love it that sounds great.
So I've been poking
around in the new content
and I saw some new yoga videos
that I was really excited to see.
There's a fun one where
they do animal poses.
So yoga poses that are named
after animals and all of that.
So with that and other
things, what have you got,
what have you folks released
over the past a few months?
- Well, yeah, I'm glad
you noticed the yoga.
I'm so excited about that.
So Khan Academy Kids and
it's the same at Khan Academy
this time of year is really busy for us
because we are releasing
a lot of new content
and features in time
for the new school year,
so that teachers and students
can get excited about them
as they get learning after the summer.
And so we worked really hard
this past, really the past year
to build a lot of new content.
You mentioned the yoga that
was part of Khan Academy Kids
is really about thinking
about the whole child,
not just their ABCs and one, two, threes.
And so we've always loved
getting kids up and moving
and fostering this idea that being ready
for kindergarten and
ready to thrive at school
is about more than just academics,
kids need to know how
to be in the classroom,
they need to be confident and healthy.
And so we partnered with Alo Yoga
and they have a part of their
program called Alo Gives.
And Alo Gives is now fully featured
in the Khan Academy Kids app.
It's a set of videos there a few minutes,
anywhere up to about five
minutes long with real people,
real kids, real yoga instructors
which I'm excited about.
- It's not Kodi Bear doing yoga.
As much as we would love to see that
and Kodi certainly loves yoga
and loves to keep fit and healthy,
we thought our friends at Alo Gives
could really help show us.
And it's been amazing Kristen we have had
lots of families sending
in the most adorable videos
of them all, the whole family
sometimes getting involved
in doing their movement
and mindfulness each day.
And for teachers, we think
this could translate well too,
because we're seeing lots
of teachers projecting
the app on their screen,
if they're lucky enough to
have one in their class,
or if they're teaching
remotely to share their screen
over Zoom or whatever
platform they're using,
and then we can all do yoga together.
So it's something that
we're seeing used at home,
we're seeing it used a
little bit in classrooms
and we're just super excited about it.
I know yoga is a really
important part of my life
and my mindfulness and so yeah,
can't wait for kids to discover that.
- That's fantastic.
So you talked about some of the new titles
that are available too,
can you give us a little bit more detail
on some of the books
that are available then?
- Yeah, so big part of the latest release
that we're really excited
about the back to school
is covering second grade.
So we had a bunch of
kids who were just flying
through our app, they
were quickly running out
of activities.
And so we couldn't keep up with them.
They were gonna get through
all of the first grade content, for sure.
So we have built out second grade content.
So we added over 200 second grade lessons.
We added over a 100 new animated videos
that are in the app and
all that animation is done
sort of right behind me.
You can see the little
Kono where we put together
the animations of our characters.
So you can see Sandy the
Dingo and Peck is the bird
and Ollo the Elephant
and Reya the Red Panda
and Kodi the Bear.
Kodi narrates and takes
us through the app.
So added all those animations
that cover a range of activities.
We added more coloring
pages in our create section,
which is really, really fun.
We talked about the yoga that we added
and we've added new books.
So Khan Academy Kids is a
combination of our original books
that are all created here in-house
and then also some partner books as well
and we partner with National Geographic,
so Young Explorer and Bellwether Media
on our non-fiction books
and we added a ton of
new non-fiction books.
Some of them get really deep
in the science of things
and just super interesting.
And so if you go into the app
and then go into the library,
you will see most of the new content
if you're in second grade
and you'll see these banners
that say new and you'll
see the yoga videos,
and you'll see the new Bellwether books,
and you'll see a bunch of
new original readers as well.
So we're just really excited,
we think we might have a
chance this year, Kristen
of keeping up with all those learners
who are just racing through our content.
(Sophie laughs)
- It's a good challenge to have
to try and reach them
and keep up with them.
That is great, excellent.
So you talked about
classrooms and teachers,
and I know that that's been a push too.
What have teachers told you that they want
and how have you met
some of those requests?
- Yeah, well, firstly, I just got to say,
and it doesn't get said enough
and I think that teachers are absolutely
incredible and amazing.
We had teachers during
school closures last year
reaching out to us and
they were so quick to adapt
to online learning and they
were sharing their screen
with the Khan Academy
Kids app and then we built
an assignment speeches
so that they could assign
targeted lessons for students
who were working at home
and then they have progress
reports where they can see
what is going on.
And we got a lot of
feedback when we launched
those features, the
assignments and the reports
really designed for remote
learning at the time
that the teachers were enjoying it,
they were loving it and
they wanted even more data
and they wanted even better ways
of assigning the right thing
to a student at the right time,
which we were really happy to hear.
So we just launched a new
set of teacher reports
and so this is accessible
if you do a log into the app
as a teacher you'll see that
there is a assignments section
and a report section and now teachers
can assign directly from these reports.
That's one of the biggest changes we made.
So you can imagine if
you're a teacher and you see
that a student's struggling on something
and you want to reassign it,
you don't wanna go back
out into the library,
find that thing and assign it
that would be really clunky.
And so now you can assign
directly from this report
and it's really quick and easy.
The other thing that
teachers were asking for was,
I wanna see a student's
score history on each lesson,
I don't just wanna see
their latest attempt
or their best attempt I wanna really know
did they exhibit a growth mindset?
Did they really work
hard at mastering this?
How can I see the journey to
getting to that check mark,
if it's a green check mark?
And another big thing and
this is especially important
when there has been
suspected learning loss
is that teachers and
parents for that matter
can see how far a student has progressed
in a particular learning domain.
So they can start to see,
okay, that might've been
a little bit disrupted,
we spent some time out of school,
we spent more time outdoors,
we learned more things around the house
all those were good things
and now it's great to have
a sense of where we're at on
a particular learning domain
and a learning domain might
be a component of ELA,
or it might be a component of math.
So like counting might be
part of a learning domain
and we'll get a good sense
of where a student is at.
So all I can say is hats
off to our teachers,
we're training them already.
Every year it feels like
they're even smarter
about our product, Khan
Academy Kids than we are.
They're teaching us a ton about
what works and what doesn't
when you actually take it into a classroom
or virtual learning setup.
And yes it's a joy.
We have some Khan Academy
Kids ambassadors as well,
and they are really
amazing group of teachers
who are spreading the word.
And to that end, if anyone listening
whether you're a student or a teacher
or a district administrator or a parent,
or none of the above,
if you know of districts
that would like to work with us,
preschools, particularly
headstock preschools
were so interested in reaching them.
If you know teachers, if you know parents,
I mean, spreading the word
anyone who is involved in the education
of two to eight year olds should know
about Khan Academy Kids, I think.
- Excellent.
So I know in that report
that got flashed up there
on the screen for a minute to folks
I managed to catch that
one of the things that
we talk about a lot is mastery learning.
And that it's not just
about getting a score
on a particular assignment,
but thinking about mastering a skill.
And so when you're talking
about domains like counting,
instead of thinking about,
what was my score on this assignment?
It's thinking about how well
do I understand counting.
And it looks like your
reports are designed to help
kind of teachers do both of those things,
understand how a student did
on a particular assignment,
but also that broader
domain and understanding
how they're making progress on that.
Is that a fair statement?
- Yeah that is a fair statement.
And it wasn't always
that easy to aggregate up
to the skill or domain
level and that was something
that our teachers asked for.
And so that is really
part of this new release
that we launched just
a couple of weeks ago
and that teaches us starting to use.
Yeah, that's exactly right.
- Great, great.
So you talked a little bit about last year
and the challenges teachers
faced and where they were.
Unfortunately, it looks like
we're not out of the woods yet
and some of these challenges
in getting kids to school
and where things are,
and I'm starting to see
some headlines about what
attendance is looking like
coming into school particularly
for young learners.
What are you saying related to that?
- Yeah, I think we had
heard throughout the summer
all about the excitement
about heading back
into the classroom and we
are still really hopeful,
all the amazing work that's
going on at the state
and district level to make
that safe for students,
I think is just incredible.
There is some hesitation
when it comes to getting kids
back into classrooms and we are seeing,
and I think that's what you
were referencing Kristen
is that the absence is really concentrated
in those younger years.
So I think what some of the numbers
coming out of places
like Stanford University
in the last couple of
weeks show when it comes to
enrollments in public schools is that
there are lower enrollment
levels across the board,
and there are even lower
enrollment levels for lower grades.
And kindergarten is looking
like the hardest hit
and that is really a key age
group for Khan Academy Kids.
And so some of the numbers we have is that
there are a million children
who were expected to be enrolled
who are not enrolled and not
turning up to school so far,
time will tell and
close to a third of them
are kindergarten students.
And so I think what I can
say to folks about that
is that Khan Academy Kids whether
there's learning happening
at home or learning
happening in the classroom
Khan Academy Kids is a
tool that can support
both arrangements.
So we have parents who are working
on a lot of learning with
kids at home and they are able
to chart the progress
of their child at home
and then share it with their teacher,
whether they're learning
remotely through something
like Zoom, virtual school
or whether they do in fact,
make it back into the classroom.
And so that is one way we're
supporting parents and teachers
at this time, particularly
with younger kids,
particularly if they're
not ready to be back
in the classroom yet.
And I think we will be able
to show up on the screen here,
some resources we have
here and we'll put a link
in the chat and we've
got a link out there now
Khan.co/KhanKids-ParentResources
and this is where parents can
go to get a list of resources.
And really these are around
things like structuring time.
So how might a parent
plan the week or the day,
there's a link there you can
see now called printables
and that will link to
a bunch of activities
that really go beyond
being ordinary worksheets
they will link to the app.
They will have activities
that are out of the app
and get kids moving,
they will have cutouts,
they will have craft,
they will have creativity.
So you can see some of these printables
are really helping parents at home
because we wanna balance
that screen time on our app,
learning with our characters
and working through printables.
So they're just some of the ways
that we're supporting
learning at home and we're-
- So let me pause.
Ashley Clark on YouTube hopefully
that answers your question
of whether Khan Academy
Kids can be used to
for parents who are
homeschooling their kids.
So I didn't mean to interrupt you,
but that question had just come in
and thought it was right in line
with what you're talking about.
- Yeah, great.
I think Ashley you saw that URL there
reach out to us at Khan
Academy Kids Support
if you have any trouble finding anything
but I think the beauty of
it is it's not all in app.
There's a lot going on
outside of our app as well
for those little learners.
And yeah, we've got a lot of parents
who are relying on those
resources for a good part
of their learning program
with their kids at home.
- Excellent.
And so let's take a look at kids
who are going back into classrooms
and what we can do to support them.
- Yeah.
Well, I think one of the big things
and it sometimes feels a
little bit counterintuitive
because there's a lot of stress
about learning loss going on
one of the big things
that we're hearing is
let's take this slow when
it comes to picking up
new resources and getting
right back into learning,
let's make sure kids are feeling
confident in the classroom.
Everyone's been through a lot this past,
more than a year now.
And so we are really, really excited
for kids to get back and
to meet their friends
sometimes for the first time
to meet their new teacher.
And then as learning begins
we're working with teachers
to weave Khan Academy
Kids into the school day
and into homework or work
that's done from home.
And we are partnering
with school districts
and we are partnering with preschools,
particularly headstart
grantees across the country
to support teachers and to
deliver Khan Academy Kids
to as many students as possible.
So if you are a school
district administrator
or you know of one,
you can email
KhanKidspartners@khanacademy.org,
and that's where you can reach one of us
who will help support
your district or preschool
to get Khan Academy Kids out
there for parents and teachers
and most importantly for students.
- Excellent.
All right, I'm gonna take
another fun question from YouTube.
Cookie wants to know
why is Peck a baby bird?
(Kristen laughs)
- Well, this is actually
putting me on the spot,
I don't know how old Peck is.
Maybe one of our super
users knows more about Peck
more than I do.
Like is certainly the smallest
of at characters in size,
but certainly a very, very
interesting, diverse character
don't let size fool you
when it comes to Peck,
but I'll have to check
without our creative team,
our animators, our illustrators
here who created Peck
to really check in on why
he at least seems younger.
I'm not sure that he is, but I'll check.
- Excellent, excellent.
It's always good to stump the host
and the guests sometimes,
so good question.
(Kristen laughs)
All right, we are just about out of time.
Let me just close by asking
what are you most excited
about in the year ahead?
- Oh, I think it's gotta be
seeing kids back in school.
I mean, I think I took it for granted
going out and visiting
schools and all the noise
and the mess and the joy
that goes with a classroom
that's in full swing and I
am just so excited Kristen,
to see that again, to see
kids spending time together
and to get off Zoom.
So we might have to wait a little longer
and I'm glad everyone's
being really patient,
but I have to say that that is my dream
for this coming school year.
- Excellent.
Thank you so much for joining us.
Thanks to all of you
who've been listening.
Khan Academy Kids you can
find it in whatever App Store
you use and prefer for your devices.
Thank you And we'll see you all next time.
- Thanks Kristen.